one moment that will stand out forever
is when I woke up one day early on
starting my business and I had fifty
orders for this one dress and I just
woke up and I was like I've never even
had fifty orders before and now I have
fifty just for this one dress like what
am I going to do and that was a moment
where I said you know what I'm gonna
focus on the business I'm gonna grow it
and I can do this and people are paying
attention and it just went from there hi
my name is Candice Gallic I'm 29 years
old and I'm the founder of bikini luxe
bikini luxe is an online retailer that
specializes in designer somewhere resort
wear and accessories my billing afforded
me opportunities in the industry where I
got to meet the designers and the owners
of summer brands and and those
connections really helped me once I did
grow my own business
[Music]
I started by putting the items that we
had for sale on different social
shopping platforms that already had a
strong customer base that were looking
for somewhere and and clothing items so
that helped me to gain the first few
sales and momentum and from there on I
just reinvested all the money into a
more inventory and just kept the ball
rolling
[Music]
originally I thought that just by
focusing on customer service that would
set us apart and I quickly learned that
our competitors were much larger than we
were and they had great customer service
as well so we started choosing brands
that were harder to find in the in the
US maybe they didn't have any
distributors in the US we started
sticking to brands who had a really
strong mission so some of the brands
that we carry only employs single
mothers in Colombia for other ones take
women who are facing homelessness or
abuse and teach them the trade of making
jewelry and they sell those and provide
those people with living wages so I
think that we're different in that
everything we do is is thought-out and
there's a there's a reason why we pick a
brand and it's not just because there's
a high profit margin it's because
there's a story and and they're actually
doing good in the community
[Music]
I wish that I could say that a single or
a particular person inspired me on a
daily basis but it's ever-changing you
know I think that a lot of the larger
ecommerce websites I've learned a lot
from them you know and I I look to them
for inspiration and and I try to
pinpoint what it is they're doing right
and what it is that they're doing wrong
and focus on fixing what they're doing
wrong my competition is not the person
who's next to me my competition is this
multi-million dollar company who's
selling somewhere so it's really pushed
me to strive for more
[Music]